[Music]
welcome to my review of Star Wars
Battlefront 2 ei what that's not what's
called I'm sure what it looks like I
mean it looks like it's called Star Wars
Battlefront 2 ei I mean I that's what I
thought it was called in my life I can't
recall a game that's been surrounded by
this much controversy Battlefront 2 by
EA was a game that a lot of people were
looking forward to playing I didn't
really enjoy EA's original Battlefront
all that much I thought it was okay at
best but a very expensive game with
expensive DLC that felt unfinished upon
release so when it came to battlefront 2
I was hoping that they would add some
things like a really good single-player
campaign for instance and there is a
single-player campaign in battlefront 2
now when it comes to all the loot boxes
and pay2win and the choices that EA has
made when it comes to releasing this
game there's been enough talk about it
already people are mad people are very
mad and I'm one of those people I was
going to buy this game and I decided not
to I couldn't bring myself to support
them so I kind of life hacked
battlefront 2 there's a rental chain
nearby my house called family video it's
basically Blockbuster and it's still
thriving and very successful you can
rent blu-rays and older movies and video
games and I went in there and I saw a
copy of battlefront 2 and I said to
myself huh I wonder where the profits of
this go and I went up to the nice lady
and she said yeah I mean all the profits
go to us ea doesn't get a dime and she
knew exactly what I was talking about
too which shows you just how widespread
this controversy has gone so for 8 bucks
I got the game for a week and I
rear-ended it and had it for a second
week and I've played through the
campaign I know there's more coming out
when the last Jedi was released but I'm
gonna talk about the campaign that I did
play as well as some of my multiplayer
experiences and a lot of glitches that I
caught and I'm by no means a
professional video game critic at all I
don't know all the terminology I am very
much so a noob when it comes to
describing
these types of things so the way I
approach reviewing video games is
usually just did I have fun with it did
I enjoy myself was it broken did I feel
like I was cheated all of these things
things that I experienced in Battlefront
- yes they are I I had fun you know
there were times where I enjoyed myself
and I'm not gonna sit here and act like
this is the worst game I've ever played
because I've played Superman 64 and
that's just not true however it is
rather disheartening to see the things
that EA has done with the Star Wars
Battlefront games because the first two
are amazing battlefront 2 is one of the
best Star Wars games ever made I had so
many great experiences with that game
and I still look back on those memories
very fondly and it's not just nostalgia
it's a damn good game when it comes to
these newer battlefront games they feel
insanely repetitive battlefront 2 has
some fun combat and it has some very
challenging sequences and in the
campaign you get to play as a wide
variety of great characters and all of
the acting is actually quite good and
one of the best things I can say about
this game is that the cutscenes are
phenomenal this is some of the best I
have ever seen when it comes to
rendering a person looks great some of
the best graphics on ps4 without a doubt
and I thought that it was very
impressive the campaign is a fun Star
Wars story and if you're a big fan
you're gonna want to experience that I
found myself fairly invested in iDEN the
lead character more the members of
Inferno squad as she deals with a crisis
of conscience as she experienced things
in the Empire that don't quite mesh with
her and she feels like maybe some things
aren't going the way they should it was
an interesting story and I had a fun
time playing it for the most part but
the game just became extremely
repetitive after a while because it's a
lot of duck for cover shoot duck for
cover shoot you get to play as different
characters and so it feels like there's
some variety and there's a lot of
different worlds just like any Star Wars
experience but it's all basically the
same stuff over and over and over some
of the same things that bug me about the
first battlefront by EA are also getting
on my nerves here and that's that it's
basically bad
a field or something like that it feels
like any other shooter action game that
you could play you're just either
holding a lightsaber or you're holding a
blaster that's not enough variety for me
in a Star Wars game I miss LucasArts a
lot I loved
LucasArts I thought they did some really
great stuff with Star Wars games in the
past the original battlefront shadows of
the Empire Rogue Squadron rogue leader
this game just didn't feel fresh to me
it felt like a myriad of other games I
have played before you're just
experiencing it as a Star Wars character
and so it has that novelty where you can
be like wow you know this is it's Star
Wars and then you sit back and you're
like am I ever going to want to play
that level again am I ever gonna want to
actually do that again probably not
because it's just a lot of the same but
I can say that I am happy that EA did
give us a fairly good single-player
campaign with battlefront 2 because the
first one No so I was happy that I was
able to at least experience for a few
days a fairly enjoyable campaign despite
its repetitive nature now when it comes
to the multiplayer I played it for a few
days online my friend Matt play it with
me too there's a lot of different
scenarios that you can engage in and
various characters that you can
eventually unlock if you do well enough
and of course if you pay enough which is
just bullshit man I better not get into
that otherwise we gonna be here all day
when it comes though to the multiplayer
it's just like the campaign it's
immensely repetitive you do the same
stuff over and over and over and it's
just not that fun you can play this game
and you can shoot a bunch of
stormtroopers over and over and you can
pass the time this is my best way to
describe it
the way I view a great video game is
similar to the way I view a great movie
can you watch a great movie or play a
great video game and feel actually kind
of invested in what you're doing or can
you have a movie on in the background
and it's playing and it's entertaining
you but you're not really paying all
that much attention when it comes to
battlefront 2 that's how I feel you can
play it and it can pass the time but as
soon as you
turn that TV off it's just it's gone
it's out of your mind you're not even
thinking about it anymore because it's
just a lot of the exact same stuff over
and over again now I mentioned I
encountered some interesting things in
the game here's one I killed this
soldier and then he decided to dance
while he was dead I'm not exactly sure
what was happening there
the exact same thing happened to a
stormtrooper but that just seemed to be
his arm that was affected it was like
when they died parts of their body
became possessed and like it just wanted
to survive but the rest of them didn't
during one of the TIE fighter missions
my ship attached itself to another ship
like a magnet and then slid across it
before blowing up so that was fun and
when I played on Kashyyyk as Darth Maul
my character decided to walk to the left
and commit suicide
I wasn't pressing left that just
happened things like this occur
throughout this game and it just angers
me that a game is released and it's
available and I'm playing it and this
stuff happens this is like unimaginable
on something like Nintendo switch I
didn't encounter anything like this in
breath of the wild or Super Mario
Odyssey which by the way is great and
you should play it even splatoon too or
arms games for the switch that I have
already played in B I don't encounter
any of these things because Nintendo
does not use its release day as a test
they test their games before they
release them and the TIE fighter thing
reminded me to talk about the flight
missions the controls at first really
got on my nerves the fact they separated
two control sticks the left one kind of
controls spinning and the right one can
do more 360 movements try spinning
that's a good trick oh god this game is
infecting me but after a while I found
myself enjoying them although there's a
lot of graphics that pop up like destroy
and eliminate and reach hovering over
your objectives that was just very
annoying and it felt just like I know I
can shoot the TIE fighter I get it there
right there I get it okay like some
people want to know where everything is
and they like that ease but I remember
the good old days of rogue leader where
you actually had to fly around and
search for ships to destroy there wasn't
like some thing saying there it is you
had to find it I miss getting invested
in a world like that
the
Fleur a sheen of it the design that the
the feel of jumping into something and
when you turn it off you're actually
still thinking about it this game is a
time waster Battlefront 2 could have
been so much more I haven't even gotten
into the pay2win stuff and I'm not going
to because I didn't try any of it
I refuse I refuse I didn't even want to
buy the game if you guys want to play
this game I would suggest going to like
a family video if you have them in your
area or some other rental store that
allows you to rent a game that doesn't
give any of the profits to EA and let me
also reiterate if you bought the game
please I am NOT saying that you're a bad
person or something like that's your
choice that's entirely up to you my
choice is just that I can't support them
I I want to vote with my wallet and I
feel like if a lot of us do that when EA
makes another one because they probably
will maybe it'll be better maybe it'll
feel more like the Star Wars we wanted
to feel like who knows if you have a way
of renting it I would do that because
then you're supporting a small business
you're supporting rental stores or
that's just that's just awesome instead
of like this big conglomerate
corporation that just wants your money
to open up some loot box thing that
nobody cares about I'm gonna give Star
Wars Battlefront to a six out of ten I
feel like I was really fair there was a
lot of things about this game that
bugged me but I was able to have a few
days of fun with the campaign at least
without having to worry about the
pay2win stuff I didn't get too involved
with the multiplayer so I couldn't give
you that much information about my
experience with it besides some of the
glitches that I experienced but overall
it's yeah so yeah guys thank you so much
as always for watching I look forward to
seeing the last Jedi very soon you guys
are the best and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]